einmal mit unheimlichem charisma und
einer unglaublichen geschichte die uns
jetzt als spielfilm fest
als ich das skript das fand ich es krass
das war fast meine geschichte er spielt
einen termin tiger der jahrelang im
blutigen bürgerkrieg in sri lanka kämpft
und dabei frau und kind verloren jetzt
hat er genug von mord und totschlag und
der sortiert er versucht mit einer
falschen familie zu fliehen
der schicksalsgemeinschaft gelingt die
flucht in einer heruntergekommenen
siedlung in einem pariser vorort findet
die pan eine wohnung und eine anstellung
als hauswart die fremde ist ein kultur
und sprache schock doch dies ist
feindesland
hier sind sie nicht willkommen sie leben
in einem klima der gewalt und des
misstrauens hauptdarsteller anton itas
an jesu kasan genannt lebt selbst in der
pariser banlieue auch er ist ein
flüchtling aus sri lanka ein glücklicher
zufall
der berühmte regisseur jacques audiard
entdeckte ihn beim casting in der
tamilischen gemeinde in paris er kannte
mich vorher nicht und erzählt doch von
mir
das reizte mich und ich wollte auf das
thema flüchtlinge und bürgerkrieg
aufmerksam machen
schober war der zweite oder dritte von
vielleicht 100 kandidaten am casting
er hat ja schon bei den ersten tests
verblüfft war fotogen hat er ein
gutmütiges lächeln war verführerisch
das macht mich sehr an ihm ich wusste
sofort der ist der richtige die pan und
seine familie finden im exil nicht die
ersehnte ruhe
auch hier herrscht krieg einer in dem
sich tag und nacht die drogen bergs
bekämpfen
ein gnadenloser kampf ums überleben
den kennt schauspieler schober aus
bitterer erfahrung doch davon hat der
regisseur jacques audiard gar nichts
gewusst bei short notice in rezession
spaß vergangen retter fuhr ich erst
während der dreharbeiten bei einer probe
musste eine szene spielen er sagte mir
ich weiß wie ich das spielen muss
daraufhin haben wir uns unterhalten und
er hat mir alles erzählt dass er kinder
soldat gewesen dass er mit 15 jahren zu
den themen teuersten dass er gekämpft
hat abschied vom getöteten kameraden im
bürgerkrieg da spielt einer sein leben
vor der kamera
wer so brutale erinnerungen mit sich
trägt für den könnten die dreharbeiten
zur qual werden
das ließ mich kalt
gewalt habe ich im krieg täglich erlebt
400.000 10.000 tote die ich gesehen habe
haben mich abgestimmt
meine emotionen sind gefroren dann habe
ich sie auch beim film nun griff die
zusammengewürfelte familie hingegen hat
mit inneren konflikten zu kämpfen
alle haben offene wunden mit zunehmender
bedrohungen von außen jedoch wächst das
trio zusammen eine liebesgeschichte
beginnt die zweckgemeinschaft wird zur
echten familie
das verleiht den entwurzelten stärker um
zu überleben
da unterscheidet sich die bahn von
seinem darsteller schober schreibt
bücher als überlebensstrategie und
spielt in einem film wie diese mit sein
ziel ist nicht die integration sondern
die rückkehr in pazifistischer gesinnung
ich habe hier nichts verloren
ich will zurück nach sri lanka aber
nicht als tourist sondern als politiker
und schriftsteller als einer dessen
stimme anerkannt und gehört wird und als
einer der ohne war etwas verändern kann
alle gesetze die die es erlauben wirken
gibt es dort noch nicht in der bauhöhe
gelten die gesetze der drogen los als
die gewalt eskaliert erwacht im
ehemaligen rebellen die bahn der kämpfer
was einer erlebt hat das schüttelt er
nicht so schnell ab erst recht nicht an
einem ort wie diesem